الهجمات في كابل لا تتوقف ما بين تفجير
ومحاوله اغتيال عاشت العاصمه الافغانيه
ساعات من الفوضى والتنديد
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني شهبا شريف مدد
بمحاوله اغتيال رئيس بعثه بلاده في كابل
واوضح ان منفذ الهجوم فشلوا في ايذاء
الدبلوماسي الباكستاني لكنهم اطلقوا النار
واصابه حارسه الامني فيما ادانت الخارجيه
الافغانيه الهجوم واكدت انها لن تسمح
بالمساس بامن البعثات الدبلوماسيه
قبل ذلك بقليل شهدت كابل تفجيرا وقع
بالقرب من المسجد الذي يلقي فيه الزعيم
الافغاني قلب الدين حكم التيار خطبه
الجمعه السياسي الافغاني نجا من محاوله
الاغتيال فيما قتل اثنان من المهاجمين
اضافه الى مقتل احد الحراس واصابه اخر
ياتي كل هذا بعد ايام من اعلان حركه
طالبان باكستانيه عزمها مهاجمه قوات الامن
الباكستانيه في جميع انحاء باكستان
وتعاهدت بالرد على الحكومه في كل ركن من
اركان البلاد وذلك فيما وصفته برد الفعل
على استفزازات قوات الامن الباكستانيه
ملوك الشيخ العربي